I used to struggle reading the Quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app I never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for IOS
and Android and build your habit with
the Quran right now
brothers and sisters
we're gonna get straight into this video
this video is about Sir specifically a
Muslim brother who is claiming that he's
involved in sir what kind of what kind
of magic is this there are two types of
magic one which is illusion number two
is actual second that is done by working
with the Unseen to cause harm or have
benefits from them we're going to tackle
this issue inshallah and talk about the
brother himself why is involved his
Hereafter his repentance and in general
and I'm not sure what this means for us
inshallah and what we can learn from it
here is the video Let's dissect it one
by one inshallah see I just got another
comment now on my Tick Tock saying um
you do black magic you'll never go
Heaven it's just like comments like this
as well cool I might do it but it's just
it shouldn't it shouldn't affect you and
not only that it's like um there's
another story okay so just the first one
touch upon him going heaven or hell we
do not know that but what we do what we
do know in general ruling and we're not
doing we're not going to Province people
we're giving General rulings here is
that the one who's involved in sir
becomes a disbeliever can they repent of
course they can repent what is a ruling
for that pertaining that we're going to
come to later but his Hereafter him go
in heaven hell or not going hell we do
not know that obviously depends on what
the person dies upon which we're going
to come to later but I don't think
anyone should make comments of you're
going hell or not this actually
discouraging and cause can cause
somebody to further go to sin like we
know of the man who killed 100 people
the more he was told that he cannot be
forgiven the more he went on a killing
Rampage so it is important for us to
always open the doors of Mercy to the
believer but let's carry on
I think a few months ago my skin started
getting really bad so if you want to
give you a picture and you can put it up
on the screen yeah and show how bad my
skin was and this skin was so bad that
every hour of the day started bleeding
oh my God bleeding up my face yeah yeah
yeah
um but it's really cleared up now yeah
it's really cleared up but it's
literally started bleeding on my face
and I'll tell you white food I was only
sick and that was basically a punishment
from God because of what I do right is
that what people were saying to you or
is that something that you think no
that's something I know okay okay
another interesting point here he is
outright acknowledging that this is a
punishment from Allah now the way he
says he knows uh personally we know that
it is a punishment from Allah because if
we do something which is consequences
even if you repent sometimes the
consequences do not leave us but he says
he knows but where does he know it from
it's as if he's saying that he knows it
from some kind of a June kind or the
Unseen let's carry on watching
like this is getting deep now because
you know this is obviously my chest
loads of spots and I'm thinking they're
red as well they're not like your normal
average spots they're like red as hell
so they're like read this right and now
I'm thinking okay cool this is getting
serious now like what am I doing am I
doing it why am I not doing it yeah let
me do it then after that I'm gonna talk
to whoever wanted to talk to
um and then I was like you know what
these spots and then that's how it
slowly started getting cleared up
because I I made another deal with them
so the spot started clearing up but the
tricks are gonna get way more bigger and
impossible um
and what I'm going to do is more
dangerous because now it's just mad
because the other day I think I bought
my Snapchat
um my lips started bleeding up did you
did you see it let me show you it's
because of that deal I signed right okay
it's because of what not the same but
it's because the deal I made with them
um my lips started let me show you it's
just it's just a lot of weird things
I've been going on like I crashed my car
two days ago my lips started bleeding
it's [ __ ] out of hospitals and
everything so what I did what I made the
deal with them has made me become really
more dangerous like it's worse for me
okay I had to do it because of my
presence on camera because the spots
were too bad so now like so can I ask
like what deal this person who who this
was very interesting points here he is
acknowledging that this is a punishment
from Allah and his acknowledgment is as
if the Unseen World is telling him
disciplination of Allah now what is very
interesting is that at this moment of
time when I was watching this I would
expect him to say you know what I
learned my lesson and he mentioned
multiple stuff and spots bleeding his
tongue bleeding him having car crashes
this reminds me of an eye in the Quran
from what I can remember paraphrasing is
that Allah says and you'll probably see
on the screen
um the actual Ayah that Allah will give
you signs and signs and signs until you
push them away away in a nutshell that's
what I is saying that Allah will open
the doors to what you want because Allah
has given you calamities is a way for us
to turn to Allah and then once you
ignore them Allah opens all the doors to
you what you want no problem and then
Allah says in the end of the Ayah and
then we seize them suddenly when he
least expected it he will cease
brothers and sisters when I'm watching
this book if this brother's watching
this you're in a nutshell brother
accepting this is the punishment from
Allah and instead of repenting and
turning away brother and you still have
time for it I don't really feel like you
cannot repent you can you know like
Allah says in the Quran you know
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
don't forget this ayaki you it's not too
late
but the point I'm seeing is that as if
you instead of repenting you are like
you know what now I'm gonna go and do
another deal why would you do that Aki
brother why would you do that you are
now unless it is that as a punishment
that those spots or things were going to
stay and not go and you was more
concerned about your Public Image and at
the cost of the Hereafter you want to
declare faster so you did an agreement
with them that's how it seems to me Aki
is it worth it losing this life over
some glamor now many of you guys might
not know but I have an either condition
which I'm going to do a video about in
detail and it's deteriorating
if somebody came to and I asked Allah to
protect me and not test me with it but
if somebody came and said to me we're
gonna you know stop your eyesight from
deteriorating and but you have to do a
deal with it I'll say to hell with you
yeah I'm losing my eyesight in this life
at least Allah opened my eyes to Islam I
was blind before like that spiritually
losing my eyesight if it comes to that
why would I do a deal with the Unseen
and lose their hairafter for a mere few
years of here whatever it may be it's
not worth it so the point I'm seeing is
this it's still not too late let's carry
on watching
oh my God and this was the other day
I did see that I saw that I saw that on
your snap yeah okay now I did see that
just forget what I'm saying I did that
yeah yeah so um so who who was like the
steel made like what was the steal if
you want to dig a little bit deeper into
that because I'm a bit confused about
that comment it's just that if I say too
much things and just get worse for me
okay so I'd like to not say too much but
it was with the other side it was with
the the black magic side if you want to
call it the devil well maybe yeah okay
live with it you have to live with it
exactly so did you did you feel
throughout this process though that at
one point you thought should I should I
give up magic have you ever thought that
well you can't do that have you thought
it of course I thought it but you I
can't do that anymore because what I've
got myself into you can't get yourself
out of okay because when you do you die
so if you stop magic like that's you
think that's the end that's the end of
me like it's because of what I've got
myself into is
scary like it's genuinely scary so I
feel like that just proves that magic is
much deeper than people think it is much
deeper so okay one thing that I see is
sadly um to the bottom I don't know like
if it's that serious or this that and
you know very well this is a matter of
the Unseen and you are losing the
Hereafter at the cost of the Dunya I
mean it's not a matter to be joking
about you seem like you're very
laughing about it I don't know how
serious you are I don't know I'll be
honest I don't know how serious to take
you if it's true what you're seeing
I will just say to you look number one
there is don't lose hope they're scaring
you that oh you're going to get killed
Etc Allah will help and get you out of
this but you have to do some serious
repentance like serious repentance and
we're gonna come to the rulings on
people who are involved in this because
um you are involved in Magic which is
illusion which we cannot say is a koffer
for you to you know some Scholars might
have the opinion but it's a coffee to do
illusion Etc you know and someone's
cyber very severe with individuals who
did that actually you know um they
applied capital punishment on them
however you are talking about actual
actual Ser which is disbelief you become
a disbeliever now again doesn't mean
that you cannot come and repent
sincerely you know so the point is here
that you need to explore that and not go
down that route but let's carry on
watching okay so here he's doing some
kind of a illusion trick whatever it may
be
um can we necessarily say this
I don't know if we can really say that
here because you're just doing some kind
of an illusion so let's see what this
magic is I think of one okay cool
you think about the rapper in your mind
very good
okay cool all right
let me try this pull this off
the thing is I used to practice origami
when I was younger I was gonna say even
if you get a how you're gonna cut it
like perfectly at least in fact this
origami when I was young and um it's
coming into use now it is coming to you
I'm actually gonna be really shocked if
you can guess who I'm guessing
first time what app are you thinking of
Drake Drake yeah if we open this up now
right watch
open this up now
that's right wait what
you know I'm not gonna say I can't
really get too deep into it but you know
I am a Muslim that does magic so in
their eyes like is it right is it wrong
this and that but I don't want to get
too deep into it so yeah that's so smart
as well I know that didn't really make
sense but it's just a bit deeper than it
was before yeah yeah um no that was
actually something I wanted to ask you
obviously you're a young Asian boy doing
magic you're Muslim does that is there
anything that like conflicts with being
Muslim and doing magic as your basic
basically full-time career now obviously
a lot of Muslims or majority of everyone
Muslim says Magics are on now the way I
see it right is um everyone sins right
everyone does wrong things in this world
it's just that if I'm doing something
wrong it shouldn't it shouldn't affect
you do you know what I mean I'm going to
mygrave I'm going to die alone No One's
Gonna Die with me that's the way I see
it I know that's a bit deep but like
that's the way I think of it all the
time yeah I remember a knock down I
think it was so what's really
interesting is when he says you know I'm
gonna go in my grave Etc you know the
typical thing people who's involved in
sin you know God's Gonna judge me but we
need to understand this is not the
ordinary sin this is not your sin and
what you're doing it's not about it's
not going to affect someone else the act
of sin involves breaking up marriages
and affecting attacking individuals or
doing certain things at the cost of
losing the hairafter this is not this is
just This Way Beyond you this is this is
like you know this is on the next level
so it's really important for us to
understand I'm going to my grave yes but
what you're doing is very very severe
very very severe in Islam now so when it
comes to now the ruling the ruling is
very simple there's a capital punishment
when it comes to individuals who are
involved in this actual setup or
anything like it in a legitimate Islamic
government that's what the Sharia calls
for because their harm if you think
about it somebody might do something
like for example slander someone
Etc whatever it may be and there are
capital punishment that can be applied
but with this one why is capital
punishment is because this individual
could lie and in his household could be
harming others he can be in his
household doing magic and say it whoever
it is I'm not talking about this
specific problem they could be doing
that that's why the capital punishment
is applied immediately why to save their
harm however the scholars the scholars
unanimously agree on that one other
thing is that for example say means
he says that however if the individual
comes to the government and says to the
judge and says it look I sincerely
repent I did this and I sincere repent
without the authorities catching him
first if his catch him first is a
capital punishment if he comes to
authorities there is a room for
repentance and change their ways because
he chose some kind of remorse however if
one doesn't do that the capital
punishment applies this shows how severe
the matter is and how Allah has tested
so a message to my brother it's not
worth it brother it's not worth it Allah
sending you signs by these spots the
tongue bleeding your car crash you're
getting into is as if Allah is telling
you to turn back to him and believe me
the more you turn a blind eye to these
the more the end is going to be very
very bad not only in this life if it was
just this life you would say okay
whatever in the Hereafter bro it's going
to be severe is it worth going there
because of some glamor and fame you're
seeing Drake hit me up do you think
Drake's gonna care about you on that day
Drake's gonna ask Allah to throw you
into the fire instead of him Aki it is
not worth it it is not worth it man I'm
telling you while I when I saw this I
was so Disturbed and the fact that you
know it's a punishment and you're
carrying on doing agreements with these
people just so your sports can be fixed
up because your Public Image really
think about it well lie the daughter
repents are open it's still open bro
change your ways before it's late and
whatever consequences come with it
meaning if you lose your Fame you've got
this spot whatever it is
put up with it it is better that you get
these things as an expiation in this
life rather than in the Hereafter you're
totally as a become a disbeliever total
if you've done something you have to
bear the consequences repent and
whatever Allah sends as an explanation
or he chooses to us up to him please go
with that option all day every day
rather than losing this life in the
Hereafter all I have to say brother and
sisters I hope you guys have benefited
from this inshallah and may Allah
protect us wallahi it just shows how
much we are impacted by our society peer
pressure views Fame that people are
going down the route even when Allah is
sending signs that they are persisting
on making agreements with the Unseen the
Gin world just so they could carry on
and having these perks
it's not worth it man it really is not
worth it that's the bitter truth
brothers and sisters may Allah protect
us till next time